did you come up with the Amazon box
smile design yes how many people do you
think have seen that how many people is
is an interesting question I think that
somebody had worked it out that just the
logo printed on packaging had to been
printed on packaging about a hundred
billion times and I've just you know
that's just extraordinary Jeff Bezos
said anyone who doesn't like this logo
doesn't like puppies that's exactly what
do you say it I mean it was a Bruce so
good to speak to you how are you I mean
I'm very well I'm very well that the sun
is shining in West Dorset so I'm very
happy very hard for the people that are
only listening you're gonna have to
imagine but I've got some color in me
somehow today I've spent a couple of
hours in the garden reading and prepping
for this podcast and somehow managed to
get some color in me and it might not
come across on the thing it'll be Dean
it'll be video guide Dean filtering it
out that's the only reason that you
can't see it and first first things
first did you come up with the Amazon
Box smile design yes how many people do
you think have seen that everyone that's
listening think about the last time was
in parcel you got it was probably this
morning the fact that underneath Amazon
there's a little smiley face but it
didn't used to be like that
apparently I went on your website didn't
used to be like that used to be the
other way like if we're out like a
frowny face tell us about that
yeah so that's um how many people is an
interesting question I think that
somebody had worked it out that just the
logo printed on packaging had been
printed on packaging about a hundred
billion times and I've just never you
know that's just extraordinary
that's just packaging that's lit alone
not on its side of airplanes or lorries
websites and gift cards all the rest of
it so that's just an extraordinary thing
isn't it when you when you design
something and you're responsible for
drawing it and then it's repeated so
many hundreds of billions of times it's
just unbelievable isn't it I suppose we
didn't think it was ever going to be as
big as that obviously you know I mean
who could have imagined I'm sure even
Jeff Bezos didn't realize it was quite
as big as he's got now
it was I think we was about 20 years ago
Amazon were they that they were the the
biggest bookseller online bookseller if
you remember and that's all they did
just book selling and and that a it was
a we had a office in San Francisco and
we were working on a lot of calm boom
and the subsequent bust kind of
companies around the kind of 98 type
time and and an Amazon wanted to change
their business model from being just a
an online bookseller to sell everything
on the Internet and so the meeting with
Jeff Bezos was we need to debrief from
him was we need to tell everybody that
we're now selling everything on the
Internet not just books and we also need
to tell everybody that we are the most
consumer friendly we want to be the most
consumer friendly company on the
internet because at the time although
that seems like everybody is that now at
the time that was quite a big deal and
so those are the two things we had to
communicate and you know logo design is
about communication and so you have to
try and find the unique thing that is to
do with their name and what they're
trying to communicate so Amazon we were
lucky or we looked hard I guess there's
an a in as it in Amazon if you think of
the name and so a so an arrow that went
from a to Zed means everything right so
we thought if we could link the a to the
Z with a smile which was a sort of you
know looks a bit like an arrow but is
also a smile it goes from A to Z and
it's sort of consumer friendly which is
a sort of you know that's you know
that's the answer right to there to the
brief is it as it turned out that the
logo before had a sort of an underlined
which was a sort of like an like I sort
of frown smile like an upside down smile
so actually just by inverting that and
adding the arrow head to the end we
managed to move it sort of manipulate it
from being one look of a logo into the
new logo with meaning and that and I
think that sort of has has done as well
I mean wherever I go in the world there
is a piece of my work on someone who did
the actual piece that it was it you
drue the thing you you specifically
someone in your hi I know in my team
here's a guy called Anthony buy smiles
piles we called him after that that's
cool congratulations Anthony your works
been said billions and billions of
people am I right in saying Jeff Bezos
said anyone who doesn't like this logo
doesn't like puppies that's exactly what
do you say it I mean it was a result
somebody in his team you know you have
these that we weren't that many people
in his team it was very kind of you know
talk to the main man and the key people
but there was somebody in consumer
insights who said shouldn't we at least
test this with consumers and he was like
really if you didn't like smiles you
don't like puppies and so yes that that
is a true penny and actually this sort
of you know you try and capture a little
bit of the personality of the company in
the logo it's obviously it's just a
symbol it can't do everything but
actually he had Jeff Bezos has a very
sort of go foreing laugh and somehow
when I see that smile it reminds me of
him Jeff Bezos encapsulated in type and
but it is amazing when you you know and
I think that's part of the the joy of
graphic design you know and what I love
so much about design is that that you
know when you do create something which
has you know something good about it
that the literally billions of people
could see it you know it's not a one-off
it's it's designed to be published many
many many so legacy right it really is
very transcendent I mean hearing the
richest man on the planet behind
probably the single most popular cuz
consumer company on the planet likening
the logo that you made to puppies
there's not many higher accolades that
you can get and that right I mean where
do you go from there exactly is there
anything better than a puppy yeah no
that's it I challenge anyone listening
to tell us anything that's better than a
puppy so we've kind of skated around it
what do you do what is turn the duck
with turned up with we're graphic
designers we design logos and the
packaging and the visual identity for
brands so how would you know things that
we've done if you walk into any
supermarket and you pick up a piece of
packaging
somebody has designed that packaging and
what I mean by that is they design the
logo the colors the typography the
illustration the photography has all
been created by somebody like me and and
so that's what we do we create the look
the visual identity of a brand and the
way that sort of starts is off and on
packaging design because that is the one
piece that everybody gets to see and has
to you know it's really the closest
thing you get to the product itself so
for example we redesigned everything for
coca-cola about ten years ago probably
now and when you think about a bottle of
coca-cola you know that the closest you
come to the liquid itself is the
packaging I mean it has to and and it
becomes something inside you yeah
exactly
so the packaging becomes a truly sort of
truly iconic thing and and and yes so
that's what we've designed for all sorts
of different people and I have a company
that is has about 120 people and about
80 of those are other graphic designers
and the rest our support team that make
all that work wow that's so cool were
you guys anything to do with the names
on the coke cans was that part of your
oh yeah you had to bring that up the
same time but no that was done by an
Australian team in coca-cola lovely
anyway even the ones without the names
on they look lovely as well well it's
it's a sort of interesting you know when
you have a company you know we started
by working for lots of little tiny
little brands and so you know we
wouldn't be unusual to have seen our
work for startup so for example innocent
smoothies when they first started we did
the original bottle that's the shape of
the bottle design and that would have
been a typical kind of client of ours
back in the day and then as we got more
successful and the bigger guys came to
see us and ultimately the biggest brand
the world was was coca-cola consumer
brand and and so to design that was an
amazing thing but of course what they
loved about our work
which is the reason that we got the job
in the first place was that we were able
to get across a kind of interesting
looking design across all different sort
of touch points which is every time you
sort of see or touch the brand for small
companies and they wanted to do the same
for a big company like coca-cola which
can a coca-cola and those kind of
companies can come across as the kind of
enormous corporate giants and who wants
to you know to you know have any kind of
consumer relationship with those kind of
companies they seem austere and you know
like a big system and so you know
although we designed the packaging to
start with then we design everything
else in the way and guidelines for the
way everything looks and our idea with
coca-cola was to stop it looking just
like a big corporate giant but to give
it some kind of friendliness and you
know humanity like there are actual
humans in the coca-cola company it's
been some rather it's there there are
I'm sure there are there we are know
there are and rather than just sort of
big old corporate giant bizarrely with
the small company you already have that
brand communication just naturally you
know the size of the company everyone
knows that coca-cola is big so it makes
sense that oddly from a signalling
perspective the small company wants to
potentially look more corporate because
it signals that they have gravitas and
they're established within the market
and then you get to the point where you
have gravitas and established within the
market and you're desperately trying to
look like Jon down the road who's just
started sees little company yeah I mean
it's exactly that's exactly true there's
a there must be a sweet spot for the
type of brand of the right exactly the
right moment and you know when you've
got a brand it's 125 years old like
coca-cola it's constantly reinventing
itself yeah yes exactly that's exactly
the you know in the I guess consumers
are also looking for new things and you
know they don't want to just be buying
the same old stuff all the time and
certainly if a brand like coca-cola
starts to look old-fashioned it's been
around for a long time you know you you
can see sales drift off and so what we
do is you know keep them up to date you
know people say to me a wit
really didn't really can't really have
designed the coca-cola logo because
that's been around for 125 years which
is true and interesting that that
coca-cola script and it's called the
Spencerian script was actually was taken
from the original of that was actually
taken from the handwriting of the
accountant at coca-cola who had they
found since back in the day when had his
big Ledger's had the most amazing
calligraphic scripts and so yeah that
was s where it originally came from and
and over the years that has been
slightly tweaked and slightly tweaked to
make a little bit more legible and a
little bit more beautiful and and
although consumers and consumers and
customers and people you know I mean I
don't know I really like the term
consumers but that's what they wear this
weather we all are right and you don't
notice the difference necessarily all
the time but it stops the brand what we
do stops that kind of brand becoming
old-fashioned yeah it must be it must be
a challenge there's so many doorways I
could go down here it's like I finally
get to speak to Santa Claus and ask him
how all of the toys are made this is
kind of how it feels a little bit I'm
desperately trying it's certainly one
thing I think there is reinventing
brands that don't need to be done this
goes out to my business partner Darrin
who insists every year on us updating
the artwork for our club nights whether
they're performing well or whether
they're performing badly I'm like man
there has to be a point and the reason
that I don't like it although I have an
aversion to it is that the market
changes by exactly 1/3 or more every
year because the students leave and like
look yeah at least 1/3 of the people see
this is brand-new artwork and because we
tend toward younger students in any case
the ones that were our market last year
they've already pissed off they don't
care but with the coca-cola thing there
could be a potential where you try and
reinvent something that actually is fine
and I can imagine there be a lot of
meetings where people sit around and say
we need a new design we need to inject
some more mutant unis into this thing
and you're like maybe that's not quite
right I wonder how many brands overshoot
on refreshing the look
well I think yes I think some do but
they're actually more likely to not even
try not to go anywhere near overshooting
because they're often so cautious I mean
these are billion dollar brands you know
they really are selling an enormous
amount of product and they really don't
want to get it wrong because there are
sort of channels of promotion and
communication which people hardly ever
see or half your audience never see but
packaging is one of those things that
everybody sees and so it's an incredibly
intense process of getting exactly
exactly exactly right thank you exactly
the right color rating exactly they're
only specific your guys have to be yeah
yeah and and you and I think over the
years you know you I mean I'm an art
student I mean I that's what I you know
I started by drawing at school and
things and and you end up doing this and
what I suppose we've done is we've
become sort of enormous specialists in
we can you know there's the skill we
have of choosing the right type faces
choosing the right colors the right the
the way the lettering is drawn
illustration photography all that kind
of thing I can make things these days if
if you say I wonder if it'll be a little
bit look a little bit more classy I know
exactly what's like that you know it's
like a kind of mix it's like a mixing
desk yeah right and you just pull things
out and push things down and because we
had a all graphic designers have this
sort of you know we see in Pitt you know
we see in we would you know we're not in
words or numbers like some of your
guests have been but we see we just work
in pictures the whole time yeah yeah in
my mind I sometimes feel like I you know
I can remember so many visual things and
I can't remember the last thing I read
even if I read it to Minnesota I could
things I've seen when you have an IRA
definition retention yeah yeah yeah when
you guys are working at the its Premier
League design level right biggest
companies in the world most important
projects in the world you need someone
who
in the nicest way possible has a
freakish side to one particular domain
of their competence right you need
someone who literally can only see in
pictures can see and take the word and
you've touched on that there I want to
get into a couple of things one of them
being entrepreneurs and how how we me as
a good example can communicate with
other versions of you more effectively
and they you've touched on it they're
about the honey just a little bit more
sort of classy or can we have it a bit
more kind of you know like edgy and what
people that do what I'm trying to say is
I'm using a word which is the closest
proxy for an impression of something I
want to see and like this is that's so
inefficient like it's so many steps
removed you know but the fact you guys
being able to take that and then have
the skills to deploy it yeah that's
where I mean I think the skill is you
know particularly when you get come to
these things like a logo for example I
mean Amazon is just so it's only prints
in one color you can't I mean there's
not nothing you can do really with color
particularly it's only got you know just
a few letters and how do you communicate
all these things and so we spend a lot
of time when we've got a design figuring
out the strip that the reason why that
design is the correct design for the
client and so we would use a lot of the
words they'd use the edgy the classy all
those kind of words and and and explain
how that manifests itself as a visual so
if it's classy what is classic mean
visually I mean I know what it means you
know what in your head is that the same
as is in my head and so you could by
going through every single kind of
personality trait that they're trying to
communicate you can you can sort of
narrow it all down graphically to
something that makes sense at the end
and you can you can sort of see in a
typical presentation in a good
presentation you can see clients kind of
nodding along and nodding along and you
go so this is the answer and they nod
it's great so you often only show people
clients
you know with probably a maximum of
three solutions why you know because
actually it's much easier like it's much
much easier to if I were to give my team
designing a logo you know they go off
and and they come back and show me the
logos that they've worked on for a few
days and there's maybe 50 logos there
now I could take that to a client and I
can say we've done 50 logos for you
which one do you like but then actually
they're there then put in a position
where they're becoming me a creative
director because my job is to take but
the best and only show the very best to
the client and hone them until they're
perfect and and I think it's a kind of
lazy to show more than three is in fact
the hardest thing would be to show them
one solution because then he would have
to be absolutely spot-on it tends to be
that you should have to show clients
more than one because the way they
describe what they want has slight
different nuances so you have to just
tease out from them which one they
really mean this is a bit more classy
this is a bit more edgy this is a bit
more whatever it might be
yeah but the principle and what you're
trying to communicate through the
symbolism is is exactly the same yeah
the paradox of choices is a real thing
you know when you have you have the
entire world of shapes and colors at
your disposal to make something from
it's gonna be challenging so um you
design
you said broad like packaging the way
that products look instantly I mean if
you want to put wings on a McNuggets box
can you do it like you yes our we really
think that the wings would look good
about something having movement in it
yeah sure you can I mean it's um it's
all possible right the you have to I
think consumers are very you know they
think long and hard these days about
recyclability and sustainability and if
the wings you put on them of daggits box
asked completely frivolous and
superfluous
then they probably will think that's
exactly that's exactly what they'll
think it is Fred listen superb superb so
I think and you know we have to we have
to think like consumers I mean it's in
the last 10 years our relationship with
those kind of brands has changed because
we do particular with food brands
because of course we deal with the
aftermath of the product you know the
packaging is litter and you know whether
it's recyclable or it's not recyclable
you know we have to deal with that much
more than we used to we just used to
just throw it in the bin and forget
about it and these days we yeah we have
to sort it out and we and we're very
aware of what's good for the environment
and bad and so I think and brands that
are you know excessive you know
consumers they like them which is fair
enough okay it's I find it so
fascinating that you start with the
packaging and then and then work from
there
mmm I think it's I think it's it's so
close so close isn't it so we designed
the visual identity for Levi Strauss the
jeans you know and they're on the back
of and and they have kind of packaging
you know they have a logo on which is a
little red tab that goes in sewn into
the back pocket they have another logo
that is across the back back pocket
which is to sort of curved it's like
almost like a seagull flying seagull
kind of in in very simple terms called
the arcuate which has always been a
trademark of theirs and then they have
that leather patch that you stick on the
back of the Jean and all of those become
their packaging now that now the the
denim trousers without those elements
are not Levi's but with them and the
buttons as well with them and all the
trademarks that go around those that's a
pair of Levi's so the packaging is sort
of absolutely essential to the product
in a lot of cases and I think I love the
the way that you said about the the
packaging being the closest that you get
to the product especially the stuff that
you consume yeah and we're you know I
mean if you're you know the the logos
that you're wearing in your t-shirt you
know that's that's you know that's a
that's another form of branding and
another form of packaging yeah is what
does love the unmistakable mean what
you're trying to do is to all the time
with every brand that we work on is find
a thing that is truly unique about them
and then communicate that in their
packaging and their logos and everything
else that we end up designing and unique
is one thing and unique is we we call
that big try and be unmistakable and
what we mean by that is that like I you
know when I go on the tube and I go to
the office and I I don't take any notice
of the advert in the tube right I don't
really don't I've got my head down and
I'm doing other things and but as I got
the escalators these adverts flick past
montes corners of my eye and they are I
am registering some kind of
communication from them but although I'm
not looking directly at them and I think
that if if a visual identity the things
that we do if that's truly effective
even that little peripheral vision
actually registers that that's the brand
and because it is completely
unmistakable you know so there's a good
reason that coke color is red and and
Pepsi color is blue you know I mean
aperio
they're very different right and they're
completely unmistakable and and and yeah
so that's what we're always striving for
is to be so unique that you're
unmistakable you're right as well it's
um it does more of the work for you
having a brand image which is unique and
is unmistakable it scales itself beyond
the communication right you're right you
can just catch out the corner of your
eye I know a McDonald's when I see a
McDonald's even if I'm looking in like
oh five percent if my vision is able to
see I might add some McDonald's over
there
yes exactly whatever it's exactly the
combination of yellow and red that do
that you know those are design elements
now you know it's become very
interesting in the last sort of ten
exactly it's almost exactly ten yes it
may even be nearly eleven years because
that our design world
was was transformed when Apple produced
the iPhone because Apple which I've
always sort of thought is that a company
where they've taken design principles to
their absolute perfection I think some
that the products would be different
designed the user interface is
beautifully designed the how they use
their iconography of their Apple you
know if you if you were a an alien and
you landed on this planet and you saw an
apple store you think we worshiped
apples I mean it's that it's that strong
and match of Apple you are right yes
yeah and and what the iPhone did was it
it made everybody everybody realize what
good design was and it put the standard
way higher than it was before and
particularly for these very large brands
and the kind of the coca-cola is the
McDonald's who I think had fallen out of
step with good design and had spent all
their money in other areas of
communication and they realized that
then and certainly when we did our work
on coca-cola that we want to be as good
as Apple are we need to be as good as
Apple because our consumers are seeing
Apple every single day using this in
their hand it's in their pocket they're
seeing it every single day but that
beautiful box that cut your Apple iPhone
comes in you know those kind of
experiences are pure design experiences
and they communicate to the consumer
about quality that everything's being
thought of you know and so you know by
considering the design if they feel like
everything consumers think then that
everything that Apple produces has been
carefully considered which it has you
know friend of my work for Apple and
said to me you know we don't send an
email to anybody and this has been
through the design department because
you know if we send one email to our
Apple iPhone customers that's hundreds
of thousands of millions of whatever it
is of people is that you know you get
the design wrong there and it kind of
the whole whole is you know everything
everything's so so cohesive and so it so
I'd like to personally thank Steve Jobs
you know for promoting design in a way
that
are the other brands at that scale
hadn't done it used to be a much more
elitist thing you know where you know
good design we've seen in Opera at for
posters for operas and you know
beautiful you know expensive luxury
products and and spirits and wines and
that kind of thing and now I think that
the good design is actually much much
more for everybody which is a much
better thing an inflection point of that
was Apple releasing the iPhone that's
it's also incredible that a whole you
know it's not as if what you're doing is
new a new media you know people have
been designing stuff for ages yeah and
you can I mean look at the great logos
of our time you know that the probably
the greatest logo is I mean it depends
on your religion but I mean you know the
Christian cross is a logo it's a
representation of the of the Bible and
and you know and a great not not a great
example maybe better I mean the swastika
is also a fantastic piece of design
graphic design I mean it's a based on I
think that him the Hindu symbol for
peace I think oddly enough and actually
you know but it it was an incredibly
powerful piece of graphic design not
sure I believe exactly what the company
stood for in that case yeah I remember I
don't know whether the listeners will be
able to but I remember buying phones
like maybe like a blackberry in 2008
type time 2009 and I remember getting
that out of the box and it would be
wrapped in cellophane and there'd be
like a huge piece of documentation that
came with it and a big warranty guide
and all this other stuff and you are
right like when you now purchase
especially Apple are the elite
minimalists when it comes to this stuff
right like and you're correct opening it
is one of the most joyous experiences of
using it which is again very
transcendent very very interesting
and really you know every point that you
touch a brand who whatever that brand is
should have the equivalent of that
should be as good in whatever worship I
mean it's unlikely to be as expensive
and it's beautifully produced but I
remember we did something for coca-cola
which was they had these little and so
so we did the packaging and we did the
and all these executions all over the
world were being done by local agencies
and but one of these executions came
back and it was a and that they said oh
we always have a little drinks mat that
goes when you're on an airplane and you
are you order a drink it comes in a
coca-cola provide the little circular
drink map that goes on you on your tray
table and and and you know I mean it's a
tiny little thing right and but they and
they said oh we said how many how many
do you produce of these and they said oh
we have a we do roughly about half a
billion of those because of course the
scale the amount of drinks you have so
it's like if you don't design that
properly then you're missing out on the
opportunity of you know half a billion
because of good communication you know
what I mean
so these small tiny things can should be
treated with you know with care and
attention yeah is this integrated
cohesive and unified movement this
unified front like a like a war troops
moving in battle type thing they all go
at the right time at the right pace I
think yeah definitely seeing and you are
right like I notice a change in the way
the brands communicated
pre iPhone and POLST iPhone and it
definitely does feel like that was a an
inflection point there might be some
people listening they're thinking well
this is this is interesting from a
consumer perspective I don't really know
how communicating with someone like
yourself a creative director or it is a
graphic designer or whatever is that
interesting or that that important for
me I suppose in my in my life but I
challenge anyone to not have a problem
with a graphic designer at some point in
their life like everybody you've got
your mum's fiftieth coming up
and you've got to make a facebook cover
photo but banner for facebook or you you
brothers started a dog grooming service
so you post you post recommendations on
online saying does anyone know any good
local graphic designers and you get a
million different things that come back
so I wonder one I want to ask how as a
client and also as a graphic designer I
know that our designer journey will be
listening shoutout journey your awesome
and a bunch of other graphic designers
creatives and stuff like that how can
you ensure from both the graphic
designers perspective and from the
clients perspective that the brief and
the communication between the two is as
smooth as possible
there's no superfluous stuff in there
it's as efficient but as thorough as it
needs to be have you got some strategies
of how you do that you mean between the
client and the graphic design correct
yeah yeah yeah well well how does it
become I mean I you know I think back in
that in the original kind of graphic
designers who were originally okay like
gravity is only used to be called
commercial artists right you know and
that's what it was cool before we were
all called graphic designers and and and
that kind of tells you a little bit
about actually it's more descriptive
what we do you know it is a sort of art
but it's a for other people like it's
the commercial part you we do it for
money and we do it for other people and
there were always stories of how these
kind of iconic you know spearheading
graphic designers would stand on the
windowsill of a ten story building
saying buy my idea because it's so
brilliant and I'll throw myself up if
you don't buy it it's that good we don't
do that anymore you know we don't need
to do that anymore right
you know and so I think the the
communication is just it has to be see
what we're always looking what does a
graphic design you're always looking for
is that you know as I say we think in
pictures so whatever you say to me that
I need to translate into something that
becomes a piece of grabba design I have
to be able to put that into pictures
right so you could you could give me
some words and say really
to be exactly like this and you give me
all these sort of you know quality you
know high-end whatever it is but if I
can't actually make it into a picture
you know if I can't draw it if I can't
if it's just some things you just can't
draw because it's a feeling and it's an
emotion you just can't do it and so I
think the communication has to be like
the designer has to speak to the client
and explain that kind of thing to them
so that whatever they say they can give
them a 200-page marketing report and say
now I need a logo can you do it from
that you say well there's no way I can
condense all of that into a logo you've
only got one color and four letters or
whatever it is there's no way that can
happen so I need to I need to tease out
that conversation between the client and
the and the designer has to be teasing
out of the really really important bits
of information what do you really want
to say you know what do you really want
to communicate and then when you've all
agreed that that's the right thing then
go away and work at it and then come
back with solutions that really do
answer those four or five words whatever
it is that has to and so there's no room
for getting it wrong should you always
do your first briefing in person no
always yeah because you because how do
you know Jeff Bezos has got a guffaw
ring laughs if you've never met him why
do you know that that Smile is right for
him you know I mean you know that's not
the reason we did it but it nevertheless
is part of the personality of the
company so absolutely you know there's a
whenever you designer for example of
beer like a brand of beer you know and
you design a new beer wait if you go to
the brewery there's always you'll see
things in the despite what the client
will talk to you about you know you'll
also be observing all these different
things the way they brewed the beer the
way the hops come in the way you know
the shape of the whatever it is that the
stills or the icon of people that are
brewing there are the pigeons that rest
on those things eggs I and there's all
them and there'll be a weather vane on
top of the brewery and you'll get all
that's interesting you know or the
brewery gates will have a bit of curly
metal it'll inspire
so yeah you have to really immerse
yourself in it and sing them that I
think that's very a very um sort of
holistic artistic all-encompassing view
I think that's a really cool way to do
it I guess as well the implication is as
a client if you have an agenda and if
you're desperate for your designer to
not come up with something you're gonna
have to strap blinkers to the sides of
their eyes so that they walk through the
brewer or they would you particular
premises and don't know don't look at
the pigeon over there that weather vanes
good for you and this is the gates yeah
maybe maybe I think that there's you
know some clients would definitely make
a mistake of saying this is what I want
now can you go away and do it and really
what you think trying to do is this is
what I need to communicate how best
would you bring it to life I like that I
like that a lot so one of the things
that we touched on before we started
which I think's a really fascinating
topic is how creatives can commercialize
their ability and I know one of the guys
that works for us at the moment Ben who
will also be listening fine arts student
in his final year of his master's at
Newcastle University just an amazing
display which unfortunately never
actually got to do because coronavirus
kind of killed that but unbelievable
that phenomenal stuff that he did
how can he as a fine art student someone
is good at drawing some he's got an
interesting graphic designer anyone else
that's listening who has a passion like
you had how do they go from just being
considered to be the guy that gets water
car the girl that gets watercolors out
in a conservatory three times a year
when she's bored to someone that can
actually you know make a living out of
it how do you then make that journey
well I think you know in terms of
graphic design and I can't I I don't
really know how you do it with fine art
I mean obviously there are you know
there are some amazingly successful and
rich and you know fantastic artists
fine artists but in graphic design world
you know what we do is is we do work for
someone's got a problem a commercial
user a commercial problem or an
opportunity that they need a graphic
designed to help them with in order to
make them more
and so what we do is provide part of the
solution that makes them more successful
so we do have a value what we produce
actually has a value you know you know
that Amazon I wish I just thinking about
it now I wish we had charged for the
amount of times it'll be new impression
you could have judged you could have
charged an unbelievably low price yes
exactly
yes I should yeah we should have done
that that's a that would been a great
20/20 hindsight there and but now what
we do is we do things that that improve
people's businesses and there is a
there's a genuine commercial benefit in
us getting it right so therefore you
know we get paid for doing it and the
higher up you get in the kind of in you
know if you're the best in the world
you'll get should get paid the best in
the world for doing it and so you can
you know I think what's what was amazing
- absolutely right you know I started
off as just being good at art at school
and then went to art college and so what
future is there for that loads of people
that would just good like my mum was
just good at art but she's she's not
young Amazon's new logo company no no no
that's right so and you know it's just
you just have to do something where
there is a there is a proper financial
benefit to a client for using you you
know if you get it done properly and you
get it done well I mean you know we did
that Amazon logo twenty-something years
ago you know and and it's still being
used that's that wasn't I mean it was
expensive at the time I'm sure someone
said it was too expensive at the time
but now looking back when it was cheap
that's because it arrived in that price
down get yourself a good deal yeah and
and also I think that something to be
very aware of as a designer is that
often it is you're you know some people
think being a designer is a kind of gift
it's also kind of a curse at the same
time because you can draw things and
visualize things and you think in a
different way to a lot of other people
in business and but also you can't kind
of turn that off either so you know
wherever you go you look at your friends
house and say
we painted it but also it sometimes
they're prepared to do the work for not
much money because they just want to do
it because it's just that's just what
they do in them and so and you have to
be very careful of that because what we
do is produce something that is does it
does have a commercial value and the
benefit and so you need to charge the
right amount of money for it and so in
my business we have people who talk to
the clients about money which is who is
not me
so I can be as enthusiastic and love
from a pure design point if you love the
opportunity that's about to present
itself and truly genuinely love it and
then and then I will leave the room and
the co Bruce you need to go now and we
need to talk about money the parents are
talking now type thing that yeah if
somebody else needs to talk about the
money who isn't the person who is going
to be creating the design because I
think that then there's a it's just such
a conflict because you're so desperate
to do the opportunity but you know I
remember years and years ago my there
was a recession probably middle of the
90s sometime and 1990s and we were
working for Schweppes the the soft drink
company and they had decided that they
needed to pitch out the design for a new
soft drink they were producing and they
had a maximum fee there was gonna be
five thousand pounds to pitch because we
would never do we'd never do any free
pitching we always get paid for it in
our in our industry and and and I said
to my dad I said you know we just
started this business and I said I don't
know if I can do that I said I know it
cost me eight thousand pounds to do the
work and and and they're only gonna pay
me five thousand the other agencies said
they'll do it for five thousand but I
don't think we can do that and and he
and he said to me you know you said what
the worst what you're trying to do with
service your clients and he said the
worst service you could ever give your
client would be to go bust in the
halfway through the process of designing
because literally nobody would have
anything and nowhere to go and he said
and if truthfully you believe that cost
you eight thousand pounds
this work they need mascara actual
clients it actually it's going to cause
I'm sorry but it's gonna have to go sake
thousand pants otherwise the danger is
we'll go bust and we'll leave you in the
lurch you know if we were to win the job
so I didn't go back then I said that and
we won the pitch and they paid us eight
thousand pounds because it was it
straight for this no it wasn't a con I
wasn't really calm them out of anything
I just really want a nope just need to
upgrade my vehicle and petrels currently
like 128 so yeah I am
I really like the the idea of using
breaking the fourth wall in business
communications especially in meetings I
think that the days of very stodgy
business meetings where the elephant in
the room isn't addressed to me seem to
be very very dead and buried and perhaps
that's just my proclivity I'm sure yeah
I can't imagine that in civil
engineering
there's many like jokes that get cracked
but when you're talking about trying to
uncover everyone's biases and elicit the
responses that you all hiding and
sometimes even you yourself is someone
of you know however many decades it is
of experiencing in this industry you
might need some work from your client or
your partner's in kind of dragging that
out of you that's a person that's just
before we move on what exactly are you
trying to say we you know that that
collaborative was it zero a zero-sum
game like a but not you know it's like
one plus one equals five like that's
what you're trying to get yeah right
yeah absolutely
yes that's what you really because a lot
of people behind how in particularly
those kind of meetings hide behind sort
of standard words yeah you know the
difference between you know some brands
honestly I mean they all have the same
values they all have exactly the same
values well you're desperately trying to
do to make things look you know
unmistakeably visually you need them to
have an unmistakable difference in the
first place to be able to communicate
that and so you're desperately trying to
uncover that and sometimes it is
literally you've you've done the meeting
and you feel well okay we'll go with the
best we've got here but we haven't
really got the answer you know you
haven't really opened up and it's kind
of almost in the elevator down to
reception that you that they say whether
really I'll go back up this you know and
you go why didn't you say that the first
place so in that level and I played a
game with Richard chaton behavioral
economists the consumer behavior expert
and it was called what words I hate most
in marketing and I wondered if you've
got what words you hate most in design
so you're sitting down with the clients
off for instance I could give you one
from events which is energy it just
needs to look like it's got energy you
know it's like it's a club night like of
course it's got energy in it I needs to
uh here's another one here's an alum
three students he looks good but could
be a bit more students here what do you
mean like I I see myself writing these
briefs and going I hate me that I would
if I was Johnny my designer I would hate
me but somehow he's just got the
patience of an absolute Saint which I'm
presuming a lot of graphic designers
must have to develop yeah I think though
I sort of and also a an unwavering
optimism they could be something great
here this is xx email where the client
sent me just your [ __ ] but this time it
might be good so there any are there any
terms that you would if you were
president of global graphic design are
there any words that would be outlawed
or would be banned brainstorm into the
brains and the reason it's like you know
you do a workshop to think of ideas and
nothing ever come good comes out of them
nothing ever like as soon as I hear that
word you're gonna run a brainstorm we
can have a brainstorm with the client
one's going to get involved nothing good
comes out of them you know it really
doesn't and so that is a word that I
would just well I just like to from
creative point of view thinking of ideas
you know you need to have thought of an
idea and then go for a walk around the
park or travel on the bus and then when
you finish that come back
I wake up in the morning and go is it
still a good idea now probably not you
know we don't think of another one like
they don't happen with 25 people in a
room all collaborating and throwing
ideas they just never happen everyone
comes away from the thinking that was
great we all had such a great creative
time but we produce nothing from them I
think they're completely overrated you
have a proxy for creativity don't you
which is actually that the creativity is
being masked and volume and it's just
kind of velocity of it to this and it to
this and it to this it's like put 25
people in a room talking about anything
and they'll say a lot of words yeah and
nothing I don't think I've ever seen
anything good come out I mean I've seen
you know good connections with people
come out of them but not actually any
good ideas but actually going back to
that word student here I sometimes think
student II and people say that it you
know that idea is of its student II and
what they mean is it's a bit naive but
actually sometimes I think that actually
a student idea is pure you know it's
sort of it's it hasn't had the effects
of 30 years in the design business you
know lavished upon it so actually
sometimes the student idea can be the
best learning Dwyers you like student II
to me is actually these days I think
it's quite it's quite a good thing okay
I think what we mean when we say student
is more bottles of VK and girls it girls
in denim shorts I think that's kind of
what we're but I think from a design
perspective you're probably correct as
well so again I'm gonna ask you a
challenging question this might be like
again I did this to Richard choosing
your favorite children but do you have a
top three designs or it could just be
some that come to mind of all time there
could be your work there could be other
people's works just stuff that you love
yeah I mean I love logos I love the
FedEx logo if you have a good look at
the FedEx logo resume walk read it's
sort of a purple and orange actually you
know and what it does in between the
word fed and the word X I think it's
between the E and the X and the negative
space
is an error no yeah can you see the
little arrow in the negative space yes I
can yeah yeah and I just think it's a
you know it's a delivery company and
that's a great it's strong its bold its
distinctive its unmistakable and it's
fun little idea in it which is this in
this negative space is an arrow now
negative space is something which is the
space in between objects so when you go
to art school it's something that our
students know about and when they when
you draw a still life I remember
somebody saying to one of my teacher
saying right there's a jug and a glass
of water they said now to get the
proportion of the jargon a glass of
water right when you draw it if you draw
the space in between so don't draw the
glass and then draw the the chair next
to it
draw the space in between look at the
space in between then once then that's
what a negative space is right this is
facing between things and that allows
you to get those two things in
proportion to each other
and it's a technique that graphic
designers use all the time and so what
you're seeing in that FedEx low logo is
that I can see very quickly first thing
I look at is that and it's a wonderful
thing because it's a very and somebody
said great design great graphic design
was something that gives you a smile in
your mind like when you see it you go oh
god that's great I love that and I think
when I think that every time I look at
that that FedEx logo because I see the
arrow and I think oh that's that's
pretty smart that well I mean it's smart
that it it as a two-dimensional image
has outsmarted me for the 32 years have
been on this planet you know I cannot
see it you can't unsee cannot unsee that
now yeah I mean and people who you know
had said that about our Amazon okay you
know they're the eh-2-zed did you know
there was a small UNIX there's a to Zed
no I had no idea you know and I've seen
it I didn't know it's the arrow thing I
got the smile I was like I'll then it's
like see it's so much more than you knew
yeah well and I think that's what makes
a good piece of design is that the more
you look at it the better it gets and
that you don't want to just give
everybody such an obvious thing that
they get it immediately em is like a you
know great album cover you know the more
you look at it
you know the more you see and that's
what makes things great
I think depth of thought and you know
depth of craft similarly as well I
suppose you have to make it sufficiently
visceral or obvious for one of a better
word it has two remote very quickly yeah
Richards on the most recent episode
dropped this statistic
I think it's 98 percent of online
content is looked at for less than a
second oh yeah
so believe you're talking about an
unbelievably short amount of time so
youyou was a graphic design and not only
have to make something which is like
this beautiful timeless legacy inducing
layers upon layers of brilliance but
also immediately gratifying and
recognizable and all the rest of it and
I suppose
that's why you guys get paid the big
books that's right I think you need to
do both and it's not easy to do both
yeah I mean you know you can't not love
the the iconic coca-cola bottle can you
you because it is the curvature you know
the who did that you know the contour
bottle and now I believe I don't know
actually who did it I know that it was
designed originally by mistake in that
which is probably why it's so unique
somebody originally thought that
coca-cola had cocoa beans in it and the
bottle doesn't and the bottle originally
the top half of it the most curvaceous
top that where the shoulders are was in
the shape of a like a cocoa cocoa bean
and that's why it's got this curvaceous
shape so that's what the very first
bottle came from resonates Raymond
Raymond Loewy
yeah he didn't design it originally but
he he he sort of perfected it and one of
his one of the ways that he was
allegedly said that I wanted to be so
distinctive that if you were to drop it
and pick up a shot of that class he
knows from that shape Wow isn't that a
great before that that's so cool
I love that the fact that you could take
it to pieces and still from one
component part be able to work out what
it was yeah because it's so DS think it
was so unmistakable so that has to be
probably the most iconic piece of
packaging there is in the world I would
imagine and and then I think I'd go into
other areas I think you know I love I
love all sorts of other design you know
I love car design I think that's a it's
a it's a weird thing at the moment cars
are a weird thing at the moment they're
not so popular but the shape of a car
and that has an enormous emotional value
and a technological value and and I
think there's some you know and if you
know and these things are part of our
lives that's what I loved about them so
much all those pieces I've mentioned
that the coca-cola bottle or the car
design or whatever you know we use them
every single day you know it's not some
beautiful object that you stick on a
shelf and you you look at and say
there's another piece of design it's
things you use every day I think that's
what I love about that's what I love
working on sort of these huge brands
it's because it's it's it's your it's
your art in motion isn't it yeah it is
it really is yeah so somebody was
talking to me about when anthropologists
when they study ancient cultures and
they looked at the material culture the
things that were left behind by the
culture and from those things that they
dig up yeah archaeologists dig up they
can tell the lifestyle of the that
particular race of people so they know
difference between Saxon and you know or
and Norman because of the design of the
pieces that they find in the ground
they've no idea they've never met
anybody from those eras because they're
all dead but they make deductions based
on the material culture they leave
behind and I think that that's what we
are sort of doing as designers at the
moment we are producing the material
culture of our era and so in thousands
of years time they can say oh yeah
people you know they loved you know
Apple design they loved the curve and
there's beautiful screens and you know
they it says something about us and and
I just think that that should be the
most brilliantly designed stuff because
it's part of our lives pretty so live it
man the the implications of having a
serious
approach to it and on the surface of it
it's not just about consumer behavior
because it could quite easily be seen as
you say not once today have you talked
about conversions or customer retention
or you know margins and things like that
although that's obviously it going to be
a consideration but that's not your
consideration what you're thinking about
is is something totally different to
that yeah I mean I'm thinking about I'm
thinking that if you that if you had a
if you trying to sell more we've just
done special K right for Kellogg's right
when you yeah and it's it looks
different now and I think it looks it
looks so it's a really good job I really
like what we've done um you know what
I'm trying to do is I know what they
need to do which is sell more special K
right and you can do that in a in in a
very basic way you know you could do it
in a very basic way you could do it in a
very mediocre way but but I don't think
that you should do it in anything in a
mediocre way I mean you could probably
get more sales by I don't know making a
picture of the bowl of the cereal look a
bit better you could do a little bit of
things you know those kind of things but
I think you should you should look at
that design and you should transform it
into something that is truly great piece
of design and of course by doing that it
will get you more customer sales I mean
we're all in it for the same thing we
still want to get people defined more
special K we want to do it in a way that
gives the client the design that will
last a long time and that is is stands
out and is genuinely unmistakable
because then there's so much value in
that for the client so much value
because then when he comes to redesign
it again in five years time and you know
they can that they can build on that and
make it even more unmistakable and I
think the big sort of the enemy everyone
has to have an enemy right you're
fighting against and that is mediocrity
average mediocrity has just got to be
you know as soon as anybody does
anything that you go girl that wasn't
all that good it's such a wasted
opportunity and
and yeah we don't do that there's a I'm
gonna rehash an idea that I've heard a
number of times before and you may have
done as well it's Rory Sutherland ISM
about how people especially in the
advertising world would much sooner fail
at putting out a safe project than
succeed of putting out something which
is risky because if the risky choice
ended up somehow not working that is the
onus of that is completely on Bruce's
head he went out of his way to come up
with this real left-field very unique
offering whereas if you just follow the
formula and well we we followed that we
followed the sheet like it's just the
same as the last 10 adverts why didn't
it work oh it's okay Bruce don't worry
mate you know sometimes these things
just don't come off we know that the
formula works we'll get them next time
and I think it leads to a a real
homogenizing of the brands and you've
mentioned this with cars like I didn't
think about until now but you're right
like I've been excited by a new car
design in ages
absolutely except for Tesla maybe which
I look at start now and I still think
like you see an X especially the X is so
big and so imposing and he like oh my
god like that's such a weird cool
different sort of car it's very rare so
yeah I think people people playing it
safe especially when you've got varying
degrees of stakeholders involved and oh
you're your firm doesn't want to be the
firm that [ __ ] up coca-cola and you
know like it yes is um it's difficult
bouncing yeah yeah it would be
irresponsible to pack up coca-cola
really I think we kept many more
projects if that happen I don't think
you have either
but you can't necessarily there are
clients who would love to go further
than you think that they should go as
well you know the opposite happens you
think that creative people always want
to push clients but actually clients
sometimes always want to push designers
as well and you know we've had a I had a
spectacular failure which I'm happy to
tell yes no yeah there's a lot to learn
from it actually so we designed
redesigned mr. Kipling cakes
maybe it's quite a few years ago now and
it was at the time when Nigella Lawson
was making cupcakes and everybody was
into home baking and it Mr Kipling we're
going to relaunch as that kind of a
brand so they were going to not be there
because they're sort of charming for
what they are which is a sort of you
know every day you know in plastic baked
good then everybody knows what they're
like yes so it there was a little
something yes except I if you're right
and but there was a lot of emphasis on
making it much more of a home baked type
product and so we did this packaging
that looked absolutely spectacular and
look just like a home baked mr. Kipling
would you knows all his beautiful
photography in it look fantastic and
Nigella Lawson would have been proud of
it
and then at six weeks before everything
was due to launch the factory it is
found it very difficult to replicate the
actual products the change of product to
look as good as the actual homemade
product that we had photographed and so
they said actually what we're gonna do
is when I launch with the old cakes and
the new packaging because the packaging
loved it so everybody who saw it in
consumer research absolutely loved it
and said we would just buy so much more
if we if it looked like that and and
that was a classic so many let so many
lessons you can learn from that so they
launched it with the new packaging in
the old product and of course everyone
bought it spike in sales went through
the roof and then everywhere opened it
up Anu was exactly the same as it was in
the gaming like what was on the an sort
of you have to be truthful in in
everything that you do and and although
they wanted to move into into a new area
and be really exciting which would have
been great had they been able to produce
the product you know that there's a real
lesson that you can't you know you can't
pretend to be something that you're not
you know you do have to just be truthful
and what they should have done was just
stalled the relaunch and got the product
right and then launch the two together
that's what should have happened but it
didn't and yeah that's a lesson we've
ever having many failures but that's a
fairly spectacular
I can't believe that you've been
flummoxed by baking you've you've got
everything right and then some fellas
somewhere in the factory put too much
butter in and now you've got your
designs naqudae because what you're
trying to do is be unmistakable in what
you're trying to visualize but you're
also trying to get the truth of what the
product is out to people so that they
and an air illusion you know it has to
be honest and truthful and decent and
exciting to look at and you know and
lying doesn't work with that integration
now I think and and integrity and then
having virtue as a brand from top to
bottom from packaging to product to
pricing to a company ethos to all of
that stuff especially now with always on
24/7 communication which is seamless and
happens across the globe there's no room
to pull the wool over customers eyes
anymore
you can't be the psychopath the
traveling psychopath that used to take
advantage of every town and then I won
done there now like that snake oil
salesman my way to the next one like
there isn't there's none of that anymore
you see brands you see people say
sentences mildly innopolis I was
reminiscing about Miley and uh places--
fall from grace like it one sentence on
one podcast and that's him gone from the
entire public sphere dun ru laughs oh my
gosh Sargon of Akkad is entire patreon
gone one sentence in some bizarre corner
of the the Internet you know all of
these different people and the same is
true for bra even even more so for
brands leverage through a roof right and
actually now is an interesting time for
brands I mean because you know I was
noticing in my my essential trip to the
supermarket earlier the empty shelves
and I was thinking how interesting it
was that all other kind of funky new
brands that are out there were actually
on the shelf still but the kind of older
more trusted safe brands had all sold
out you know you know the the the
disinfectant that isn't organic and just
destroys everything but sold out you
know as the muscle is never gonna
struggle cheering up
indemic is he mr. muscle with mr.
Kipling and Aunt Bessie are absolutely
little bit at the moment they're all
having a party around they're not doing
social distance in their shaking hands
yeah it's I couldn't agree more see how
they how they're behaving and you see
you know Louie Vuitton producing a
number of others now following the same
suit producing you know some kind of
hand wipes or whatever or you know some
kind of disinfectant type products and
you think that's so that's a really good
bit of you know branding for them you
know people will remember them as being
you know a company that reacted fast you
know someone like you know Louie Vuitton
you think is so sort of so out of reach
of most people but I think the decisions
they've made as a brand in at this
moment a fantastic they are I wonder I
brought this up remember recently but I
wonder how many brands are weaponizing
goodwill at the moment I think they are
I think a lot of them are doing
something that is there is virtue
signaling for the sake of it because
they think someone in a meeting
somewhere and maybe this is just my
skepticism about brands that have turned
the corner and again what that would
imply either it one of two things can be
correct either the brands are
weaponizing goodwill and they're using
it to further their brand equity that
they can then monetize in the future or
their marketing communication in advance
of that wasn't sufficiently effective to
make me believe that they were the sort
of company that would do this off the
run back exactly exactly
it's actually poor marketing probably
and you and the ones that jump on the
bandwagon you can see them all jumping
on the bandwagon now no I think it'll
have a little effect on I think you know
your skepticism is shared by most
consumers okay really you know really
you know what they should do get Turner
Duckworth involved get too involved see
the young that need the answer to say
many people's problems I agree so a link
will be in show notes below of course
today's been a fantastic thank you so
much I loved it I've really enjoyed
really enjoyed chatting and I just think
you know let's let's design everything
beautifully let's have a wonderful
designed planet you know and the world
would be better for it that's amazing
and if people want to check out what it
is that you guys do where should they go
I'm go to turn it up with calm and
everything's on there not everything's
on there but there's about 10 projects
on there and yeah and but just look on
the internet there's plenty out there
awesome
Bruce thank you so much for your time
it's been great being a pleasure
[Music]
you